[Musique]
philippe bas sénateurs et l'air de la
manche et président de la commission d'
enquête sur alexandre ghana est l'invité
d'auditions publiques bonsoir bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous à ce rendez vous
des chaînes parlementaires du figaro de
la fp et à propos des internautes qui
suivent cette émission sur le site du
figaro bien sûr vous pouvez comme chaque
semaine réagir intervenir et puis je me
ferais le relais devant questions merci
donc à philippe et encore une fois
d'être avec nous à l'issue de cette
nouvelle séance d'interrogation de
l'ancien chargé de mission du chef de
l'état en attend bien sûr maintenant vos
conclusions après ses réponses et j'ai
envie de dire surtout ses silences les
questions ici vous seront posées dans un
premier temps par jim jara ses épaules
aux grilles à messieurs bonsoir
d'entrain puis par oriane mancini et
brigitte boucher et puis également par
deux parlementaires qui feront leur
entrée sur ce plateau dans une vingtaine
de minutes il s'agit du sénateur
socialiste jacques bigot que vous
connaissez bien qui siège dans votre
commission et du député la république en
marche
monsieur alain tourret d'abord bien sûr
philippe bas qu'elle bat quelles leçons
tirez-vous de cette audition du jour je
le disais beaucoup de refus de répondre
de la part de monsieur alexandre benalla
du coup quel
conclusion vous en tirer et quelles
conséquences pour lui éventuellement il
fallait faire cette audition c'était
nécessaire après les informations qui
ont paru au mois de décembre dernier sur
le fait que monsieur bella n'a non
seulement n'avait pas rendu son
passeport diplomatique et puis son
téléphone crypté mais qu'en plus il
s'était servi des passeports
diplomatiques nous avons d'ailleurs
appris aujourd'hui qu'il ne s'en est pas
servi seulement pour rentrer dans des
pays étrangers mais aussi pour sortir de
francs ce qui est tout différent de mon
point de vue parce que ça veut dire que
si la police de l'air et des frontières
avaient reçu des consignes de ne pas le
laisser passer avec un passeport
diplomatique
il n'aurait pas pu l'utiliser pour
sortir de france et ça renvoie au fond à
travers cet exemple précis à toutes les
questions que nous posons nous cessons
des questions sur le fonctionnement de
l'état la cave alors beaucoup de
questions et beaucoup de silence
presqu'autant que silence que de
questions alors quelles sont les
conséquences pour le principal intéressé
et je répète ma question qu'elle vous
quelles conséquences vous en tirez dans
votre enquête sur les dysfonctionnements
de l'état reconnu d'ailleurs déjà on
sait désormais par l'exécutif
alors les conséquences pour lui d'abord
qu'est ce que vous allez faire c'est
simple les règles sont claires si vous
ne venez pas devant une commission d
enquête parlementaire dont je vous
rappelle que sa mission elle est définie
dans la constitution même dans la
déclaration des droits de l'homme et du
citoyen c'est du sérieux si j'ose dire
si vous ne venez pas devant une
commission d'enquêté parlementaire vous
encourez cinq ans de prison et 75000
euros d'amendé si vous venez et que de
manière injustifiée
vous ne répondez pas aux questions qui
vous sont posées
alors vous prenez aussi un risque parce
que le refus de déposer est également
assortie de sanctions pénales vous
considérez qu'il a refusé de déposer
vous considérez qu'il s'est rendu
coupable d'une
d'une infraction pénale aujourd'hui
c'est un point dans nous auront à
délibérer qu'est-ce que vous avez
président parce que vous me le demande
on ne s'ouvre pas aux conclusions de la
commission denquête avant qu'elle ait
été arrêtée on vous a senti un vieux se
croire parle du camp mais le feuillage
de l'artichaut nous prendrons en une
seule fois l'ensemble des décisions qui
nous paraissent être nécessaire mais
vous savez pour nous l'essentiel c'est
d'abord faire la vérité sur le
fonctionnement de l'état dans cette
affaire qui aurait dû ne pas exister
s'il avait été licencié monsieur
benallal de mer ne prendrai plus
aujourd'hui
et si la suite de son licenciement
n'avait fait tout le nécessaire
rapidement pour que tous les attributs
de sa fonction soit rendue on n'en
serait pas là non plus donc nous voulons
faire la vérité sur le fonctionnement de
l'état nous voulons faire des
recommandations pour que tout ce que
nous avons sous les yeux ne se
reproduise pas et nous prendrons aussi
s'il ya lieu des décisions vis-à-vis de
l'autorité l'associer au moment de la
remise du rapport des conclusions de
formation quand les rapporteurs nous le
proposerons et quand nous pourrons
décider vous savez il ya encore beaucoup
de travail à faire actuellement nous
avons fait les auditions il était
indispensable de les faire la suite des
informations nouvelles de décembre mais
nous avons aussi poser par écrit de très
nombreuses questions ministère à la
présidence de la république aux
administrations
nous n'avons plus de 25 documents
dossiers qui nous ont été remis en
réponse non rapporteurs ont encore du
pain sur la planche
ils doivent déployer tout ça avec
l'équipe de la commission des lois ils
arrêteront les termes de leur rapport
nous en délibérerons et rassurez-vous
tout sera rendu absolument public dès
que nous serons prêts il vous reste deux
jours pour exercer vos prérogatives dans
cette commission qu'est ce que vous
comptez faire comment comptez vous
utiliser ces deux jours qui vous restent
si les rapporteurs devait proposer qu en
face de nouvelles demandes de précisions
ces demandes de précisions il faudrait
que les ministères y répondre mais enfin
à l'heure actuelle je crois que nous
avons déjà beaucoup le problème pour
nous va être d'exploiter tout le
matériau recueilli de voir où sont les
contradictions et même peut-être les un
vrai sens
lens et de dire au fond quelle est notre
intime conviction sur la manière dont
l'état a fonctionné pour pouvoir faire
des préconisations on peut faire primer
le risque que ça peut faire un point
d'étape sur votre jeu c'est ce que je
suis en train de faire oui justement
mais là qu'est ce que vous nous dites on
parle de dysfonctionnements
vous avez semblé vouloir savoir si
monsieur pénale a par exemple bénéficié
de certaines protections passe-droits
complaisance caisse quel mot est ce que
vous utilisez ce soir écoutez je ne
rentre pas dans les intentions
j'en reste aux fêtes à partir des
feuilles ou utilisez vous si vous voulez
les résultats sont là il y a depuis le 3
mai dernier une suite de mauvaises
porsche de défaillance de mauvaises
décisions de décisions qui ne sont pas
mises en oeuvre avec suffisamment de
rigueur et d'énergie ça je crois que
vous faut le caractère public de nos
auditions a permis de montrer comme
c'est à cris et leurs équipements acquis
nous a suivi le mauvais sallanches
management simplement un
dysfonctionnement circoncis j'ai reçu
monsieur grossiord vous fait
l'interprétation j'essaie de savoir ce
que vous pensez au vert c'est c'est
l'interprétation qu'il veut
moi je constate alors les hypothèses
c'est mauvais fonctionnement de l'état
nous qui avons l'administration la plus
brillante et tatillonne du monde manque
de rigueur dans le travail
oubli négligence de ne pas hésiter à
sion pourquoi pas aux tripoteurs
tricoter maintiens que c'est possible ça
parce que on a voulu ménager monsieur
benalla le résultat serait le même que
si c'était la négligence mais dans les
deux cas nous avons des raisons comme
citoyen français d'être mécontent du
fonctionnement de l'état et nous n'avons
pas besoin véritablement de faire des
procès d'intention sur des choses que
nous ne savons pas et qu en vérité nous
pouvons très difficilement savoir
en revanche les éléments de fait qui se
sont accumulés que nous avons pu
vérifier ou pas dans certains cas ça
c'est la matière de notre rapport nous
dirons au fond si les versions
officielles qui par exemple sur le
permis de port d'armes sont des versions
qui ont évolué dans le temps nous
paraissent refléter l'exacte
vérité ou si d'autres hypothèses sont
possibles c'est notre travail m'a
d'accords concrets de contradictions qui
semble avéré alexandre reynal assure
avoir déposé c'est passeport courant
août à l'elysée d'avoir récupéré début
octobre
cette version contredit directement
celle de patrick strzoda que vous avez
entendu il ya quelques jours qui est le
directeur de cabinet des manuels macron
comment vous pouvez faire vous au niveau
de la commission pour tirer le vrai du
faux de 7,2 ce qui semble être une
contradiction flagrante
j'ai eu le sentiment que les deux
versions n'était pas factuellement
totalement incompatibles mais que la
thèse de leur compatibilité n'était pas
vraisemblable à tous égards et je n'en
dirai pas plus ce soir c'est à dire que
a essayé de nous montrer qu' il avait
dit la vérité le 19 septembre c'est à
nous maintenant d'apprécier là aussi ce
qu'il a expliqué était vraisemblable et
si c'était compatible avec ce que nous a
dit le directeur de cabinet du président
de la république mais vous savez il faut
reprendre les choses notamment c'est pas
si facile de démontrer de façon c'est un
c'est un travail rigoureux
ça relève de la team conviction des
rapporteurs et de la commission mais ça
relèvera s'il y a lieu ensuite dans
cette éventualité et je ne suis pas en
train de l'annoncé de la décision d'un
juge et ça c'est encore un travail qui
est devant nous est-ce que vous avez
sentiment d'avoir entendu toutes les
personnes je pense notamment à heath
même et mes vignes enquête inverse des
conseils de proches des manuels macro et
qui est cité dont ne serait ce que dans
les articles de presse on a appris par
exemple que alexandre benalla et ismaël
rennais vient un jour où la sphère aaa
mais a été traité médiatiquement échangé
de nombreux messages et appels
téléphoniques dans la nuit
ce personnage il se met à bien peut-être
je ne sais pas peut avoir des choses à
dire est-ce que encore une fois et deux
jours qui vous reste pour elle vous
servira à l'entendre par exemple mais
vous savez cette question que vous me
posez ya longtemps qu'on se l'est posée
nous mêmes mais nous avons un mandat et
nous avons auditionné des personnes qui
nous permettent d'essayer de déterminer
si monsieur benalla a eu un rôle
important voire prééminent dans la
sécurité du président de la république
de la cinquième puissance du monde de
détenteurs de l'armé nucléaire présent
sur tous les continents avec des
responsabilités particulières du fait de
notre constitution que d'autres chefs de
gouvernement ou d'états n'ont pas et à
partir de là nous avons dû aussi car
c'est notre mandat apprécier si des
manquements aux règles qui s'appliquent
qui s'appliquait monsieur benalla comme
chargé de mission auprès du chef de
cabinet de l'elysée si ces manquements
ont été correctement sanctionnés par des
décisions de la présidence de la
république
alors monsieur
le collaborateur du président de la
république que vous citez monsieur et ce
malgré le lien ne nous paraît pas être
dans cette boucle là et nous sommes très
précautionneux la question si nous
faisons attendent chez n'ont pas de nous
intéresser à tous les éléments dont
parlent les journaux mais à nous
intéresser aux éléments qui relève de
notre mandat la sécurité du président de
la république la sanction des
manquements commis par monsieur benalla
par exemple la place de la contrescarpe
où monsieur benalla à est intervenu aux
côtés des forces de sécurité auprès de
personnes qui semble-t-il jeté des
projectiles sur les forces de l'ordre
ça ça ne nous intéresse pas d'accord
c'est pas la question d'ailleurs il se
lèvera sur les nationales mais ça nous a
bien sûr lui a rien demandé alors oui
c'est démontrer que leur disant que
c'est le message ma force des réponses à
des questions qu'on lui posait refusé de
répondre à des questions que nous lui
posions d'or et les questions que nous
lui posions pas c'était des questions
dont le juge d'instruction est saisi
tandis que les questions que tu lui
posions c'était des questions dont le
juge d'instruction n'est pas saisie
autrement dit monsieur pénale a invoqué
le respect de l'autorité judiciaire
quand ça l'arrangé pour ne pas répondre
à nos questions et en revanche elle paru
complètement indifférent au rôle de la
justice quand ça l'arrangé
celle ci met parfois au dessus des lois
et donc si vous voulez il essaye avec
une apparente gentillesse d'excusés lui
même ses propres négligences d'expliquer
qu'il n'a pas complètement pris en
compte les erreurs qu'il commettait en
utilisant un passeport diplomatique pour
se rendre avec des hommes d'affaires
étrangers auprès de chefs d'état
étrangers tous a expliqué assez
calmement parce que c'est dans une des
réseaux nalité c'est une personnalité
déjà bien affirmée malgré son jeune âge
a vécu en mai et celle qu'on met en
revanche il n'est pas soucieux d'
éclairer autant qu'il le faudrait la
représentation nationale
du point de vue qui est le mien et qui
est d'ailleurs je faisais tourner vers
locuteurs d europe
vous savez nous avons l'habitude de
toutes catégories d'interlocuteurs ne
nous intéressons essentiellement aux
réponses qui nous apporte plus qu'à leur
caractère l'avait trouvée arrogant
méprisant aujourd'hui un peu par rapport
à la première audition potes à trouville
on avait découvert quelqu'un de plutôt
conciliant et ce que je pense de
monsieur bénard a strictement aucune
importance mais pour autant ce que vous
ce que vous détruisez est ce que ça
montre pas aussi les limites de votre
exercice
est-ce qu'on peut réellement avoir une
commission denquête lorsqu'à d
information judiciaire en cours parce
que quelque part ou droit à la non auto
incrimination ça existe et si
respectable et à chaque fois sur
monsieur benhadda qui est d'une part
entendu par notre commission et d'autre
part au cas échéant mis en examen
effectivement il est coincé
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ça d'abord
je vous dis que c'est une question très
importante et évidemment elle est dans
notre démarche au coeur de notre
pratique
nous ne devons jamais posé de questions
conduisant une personne que nous
interrogeons à s'auto incriminer pour
une raison très simple elle prête
serment est obligé de dire la vérité et
si la vérité est contraire à ses à sa
défense
alors effectivement c'est quelque chose
qui lui porterait présumé il est obligé
de réponse à n'est pas du tout ainsi que
nous voulons travailler mais précisément
dans le cas qui nous intéresse
quand on demande à monsieur benalla
l'identité d'une personne avec laquelle
il pourrait travailler ou l'identité de
personnes qui lui aurait remis son
passeport diplomatique ou l'identité de
personnes de l'elysée qui l'aurait
informé de ses déplacements à l'étranger
nous sommes dans un champ qui ne fait
l'objet d'aucune investigation de la
justice même si la justice a
parfaitement le droit de poser les mêmes
questions que nous pour avoir tous les
éléments d'un contexte général mais en
l'occurrence il ya une distinction qui
en réalité est assez facile entre la
justice dans son travail et la mission
d'une commission d'enquêté parlementaire
pour la justice déterminer s'il ya eu
des infractions en l'occurrence de la
part de monsieur benalla les poursuivre
et les sanctionner pour la commission
denquête déterminer s'il ya eu
des défaillances au sein de l'état si la
sécurité du président de la république
du temps de monsieur benalla a été
correctement assurée sans interférence
de personnes qui n'étaient ni policier
ni gendarme n'était ni recruter ni
évalué ni entraîné pour assumer de
telles fonctions et ça c'est
complètement différent
je dirais même comme citoyen autant que
comme président de la commission des
lois
je suis très heureux que la justice mène
ses investigations et je soutiens
vraiment avec beaucoup de simplicité que
nos investigations ne sont pas
contradictoires mais quand les
marseillais n'ont pas même après ce que
vous avez des doutes ou peut-être des
convictions je ne sais pas sur un
éventuel conflit d'intérêts sera pour
monsieur benalla par rapport à les
activités qui ont suivi son départ de
l'elysée notamment manifestement et bien
ses déplacements en afrique aux côtés
d'intermédiaire dans des marchés divers
et variés mais monsieur benalla se
serait mis lui même à l'abri de ce type
de soupçons la fois il avait son contrat
le prévoyait saisi la commission il a
passé déontologie pour les activités
privées qu'il peut avoir après son
départ de l'elysée
les interrogations voire une conviction
déjà mais ses doutes existent bien c'est
pour ça que moi même et mes collègues
nous lui avons posé la question et la
commission de déontologie
c'est alors elle a fini elle n'est pas
encore saisi au jour d'aujourd'hui
monsieur benalla nous a simplement
répondu que son avocat était chargé de
le faire si vous voulez là aussi c'est
une anomalie et peut-être que l'elysée
aurait pu lui rappeler ses obligations
alors il a lésé que c'était dans son
contrat et qu'il avait négligé de relire
le contrat au moment où il a été rompu
il aurait dû le faire d'une n'est censé
ignorer la loi et je pense que la
présidence de la république par
précaution inclure la présidence ce
week-end par la voix de benjamin
griveaux porte-parole a reconnu des
défaillances à l'elysée est-ce qu'on a
l'impression qu'à position a évolué de
la part de l'exécutif depuis le début de
la faire est ce que vous vous félicitez
que 10 et reconnaisse enfin peut-être
des défaillances comment vous observez
ça et peut-être sur je ne vous accusez
de mener une campagne politique
personnelle
puisqu'on parle des déçus et rivaux en
réalité très heureux de constater que
l'exécutif a compris que nous faisions
simplement notre travail qui est celui
de rechercher la vérité et au fond dans
une démocratie un état de droit tout ce
que peut faire le parlement pour éviter
les excès de pouvoir le non respect d'un
certain nombre de règles
les dysfonctionnements de
l'administration doit être compris comme
allant dans l'intérêt général y compris
l'intérêt de l'exécutif parce que au
fond le contrôle n'exclut pas la
confiance et c'est un signe de maturité
démocratique que d'accepter ce contrôle
surtout quand il repose sur le fondement
aussi important que l'est la déclaration
des droits de l'homme et du citoyen dans
son article 15
nous remplissons une fonction que nul
autre que nous ne peut remplir la
justice à son hall y est éminent elle ne
peut pas faire notre travail
elle n'a pas le droit de s'intéresser au
fonctionnement de l'administration et de
l'état sauf quand il y a eu des
infractions pénales
à ce moment là elle retrouve la
plénitude de son rôle est par conséquent
si le sénat ne fait pas cela personne ne
le fera à sa place
dernière question de ce parti avec
volume dernière question peut-être au
terme de ces de ses multiples auditions
vous avez mené depuis purement est ce
que vous allez ce que vous avez
l'impression et philippe bas d'être face
à une affaire d'état
je suis toujours embarrassé c'est pour
la première fois qu'on possède question
quand on me pose une question ces termes
parce que j'ai envie de vous dire qu'est
ce que c'est qu'une affaire d'état en
l'occurrence il s'agit d'un problème
posé par un collaborateur du président
de la république dans la position
particulière à l'elysée a été révélée
par ce que l'on pourrait qualifier
éventuellement de voies de fait commises
le 1er mai en marge des manifestations
de la fête du travail et à partir de
quoi dès le mois de juillet on a
découvert que cette personne avait un
rôle dans la sécurité du président de la
république alors qu'elle n'était ni
policier ni gendarme ni membres du
groupe ont dans la sécurité de la
présidence de la république et donc
c'est bien une affaire qui
concerne l'état mais qu'est ce que vous
appelez vous affaire d'état on va pas
ouvrir le débat
question avec vous rendre vos
conclusions tout simplement la can est
venu c'est à dire à quelle date dès que
possible
c'est à dire tu peux pas préjuger du
temps que prendront toutes les
vérifications que doivent maintenant
faire à partir à la fois des dossiers
qui nous ont été remis par les
ministères un certain nombre
d'établissements publics et des comptes
rendus d'auditions nous allons devoir
confronter phrase par phrase sur chaque
sujet c'est qu'on dit les uns et des
autres ça prend un petit peu de temps ne
soyez pas impatients nous le sommes et
ce travail il ya deux parlementaires qui
sont impatients de poursuivre ce débat
peut être qu'on reparlera de l' affaire
d'état chacun cette définition bien sûr
messieurs merci donc maintenant font
leur entrée
comme chaque semaine le député et le
sénateur
[Musique]
font leur entrée sur ce plateau donc le
sénateur socialiste du bas rhin jacques
bigot bonsoir et le député la république
en marche du calvados monsieur alain
tourret salue et vous messieurs et
prenez place s'il vous plaît j'en
profite pour poser une question d'un
internaute du figaro et qui rappelle que
monsieur benalla tout à l'heure a dit
qu'il était une victime il s'est
présenté comme une victime d'une
construction politico médiatique cela
pour atteindre le président de la
république à cela que répondez vous est
ce que vous l'avez vu vous comme une
victime
ainsi qu'il se présente monsieur benalla
devrait faire du judo il en a le talent
dire que c'est vrai que quand vous êtes
dans une posture difficile il faut
absolument trouver un argument même
artificiel pour renverser la position
mais au-delà de cette analogie avec le
judo je m'en tiendrai à ce que je vous
ai pris 20 nous nous faisons notre
travail personne ne peut le faire à
notre place et je crois que les pouvoirs
publics n'ont enfin compris si j'en juge
par le contexte beaucoup plus serein
dans lequel nous avons pu m'amener ces
nouvelles audi sera bien un peu les cas
alain tourret vous allez nous apporter
ici la preuve que des critiques
peut-être à ces aides peuvent être
formulées contre la démarche entreprise
c'est d'autant plus de plaisir à le
faire que si en face de moi un normand
de la manche je suis normand du calvados
nous sommes deux juristes nous nous
connaissons je voudrais d'abord dire que
c'est un travail remarquable qui a été
fait tellement on avait l'impression que
les membres de cette commission avait
faim est tellement ils voulaient mettre
de manière malicieuse un peu leur regard
le président ben est un homme malicieux
alors ce qui me rend un peu mal à l'aise
dans cette histoire la première chose
le même jour ou à peu près de commission
denquête sont désignés
l'une par l'assemblée l'autre par le
sénat est-ce qu'on pourrait pas
envisagée dans le cadre de la réforme de
la constitution que l'on prépare qu'il y
ait une commission mixte paritaire qui
puisse être composé à la fois de députés
de sénateurs réponse là-dessus peut-être
les bains c'est sûr que ça permettrait
aux députés qui ont dû interrompre
très rapidement leur travail de
continuer à participer à ce travail très
important d' enquête parlementaire
mais enfin s'il y a deux assemblées dans
notre pays ce n'est pas sans raison et
personne n'interdit à l'assemblée
nationale de poursuivre des
investigations
quand elle les a commencé ni de les
reprendre
quand des faits nouveaux alors on part
avec on voit défiler même fier on voit
défiler les mêmes personnalités d'eau
tombons dans l'absurde
le même jour quelqu'un est convoqué par
l'assemblée nationale l'après-midi passe
au sénat et ensuite de ça il va voir les
juges d'instruction parce que ce qu'il y
a quand même de très gênant là dedans je
crois même que le président bal dès le
départ avait dit qu'il n'était pas
évident pour lui d'envisager la
convocation de monsieur benalla je me
semble t'il eu souvenirs sont bons qu'il
avait dit ça puis après il a dit oui
mais comme celui ci entend être entendu
je vais à partir du sport l'entendre si
mes souvenirs sont bons c'est à peu près
ce schéma qui a été fait sur le plan
intellectuel
moi je suis président élu commission
denquête dans un moment très très
difficile et ingrat mission d enquête de
la mnef et j'étais extrêmement gêné
parce qu'il y avait des hommes
politiques qui était en jeu et il y
avait en plus tout ça c'est une raison
supplémentaire pour être embarrassée
elle est ce que l'objectif n'est pas de
faire éclater la vérité
faire éclater la vérité oui mais la
vérité sur quel sujet tout le problème
il est là on nous parle de la ville hôte
de la volonté de faire éclater la vérité
sur les dysfonctionnements de l'état
j'ai quand même l'impression qu'on est
dans une affaire de cornecul alors même
que paris brûle et qu'à partir de ce
moment il ya peut-être des problèmes
plus importants dans le cadre de ce que
nous venons de vivre depuis trois mois
qui devrait intéresser les français
plutôt que ce sera fair bénard à jacques
bigot vous voulez intervenir peut-être
sur le rôle des commissions et puis la
répartition justement des fonctions
entre les deux chambres ne soit que
cette affaire
d'abord révélé dès le départ en mode de
fonctionnaires c'est particulier comme
dit tout à l'heure
président de la commission des lois
philippe bas si l'elysée avait tiré dès
le 2 mai les conséquences qu'il fallait
en tirer
il y aurait pas une commission d'
enquête ni à l'assemblée nationale ni a
été extrêmement brèves et infructueuses
ou chez nous au sénat le sujet c'est
effectivement il jouit de se souvenir de
l'édition de gérard collomb ministre de
l'intérieur dans dès le début aussi bien
l'assemblée nationale qu'au sénat qui
était très gênée par ce qui
effectivement révélé que monsieur bénard
avait joué un rôle qui ne vais pas être
le sien et qu'il avait été protégé
puisqu'on sait continue 30 et d'une
suspension qui n'a sans doute même pas
eu lieu
véritablement donc le sujet il est là et
si on fait le lien avec ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui c'est la même chose c'est
que ce pouvoir dit jupitérien où je fais
ce que je veux comme je veux personne ne
me dit rien a entraîné aussi aujourd'hui
les grands débats pour rattraper la
situation
notre démocratie est en difficulté et
j'entends même que dans la lettre du
président la république on entend
critiquer le sénat moi j'ai découvert le
sénat en 2014
je me suis posé la question est-ce que
c'est utile et bien je pense
qu'effectivement le bicamérisme est
indispensable et lorsqu'une assemblée
nationale parce qu'elle est aux ordres
du pouvoir exécutif
on le voit sur le vote des lois n'est
pas capable de lancer une commission
denquête heureusement que le sénat était
là il est vrai que le général de gaulle
avait une position qui me semble-t-il
été possible mais on sait aussi que le
président la république actuel
souhaiterait ressembler au général de
gaulle philippe bas effectivement le
sénateur votre collègue rappelle les
termes de la lettre
du chef de l'état qui avons conforté le
président du sénat est ce que vous voyez
effectivement dans vos travaux
aujourd'hui le moyen de défendre le
bicamérisme d'abord c'est vrai que dans
notre pays aujourd'hui il ya beaucoup
d'autres sujets de préoccupation
moi même j'ai lancé mon département une
démarche toute personnelle pour aller
spécialement à la rencontre de nos
concitoyens par un tour de la manche et
je rendrai public tout ce qu'ils m'ont
dit et effectivement nous avons cours du
mois de décembre bien au delà de ce qui
nous a occupés au cours des auditions
d'aujourd'hui constater les longues de
choc d'un certain nombre de décisions
qui se sont accumulées depuis 18 mois et
qui ont créé dans notre pays de très
graves tensions sociales au point que le
président de la république était obligé
de retirer un certain nombre de
décisions à bon escient d'ailleurs je
crois qu'il a eu raison de faire la
concorde civile et la paix sociale sur
les conditions mêmes des réformes et si
dans cette crise on réussit à partir
d'un nouvel élan parce qu'on aura écouté
enfin les français je crois que c'est
une très bonne chose mais ça veut dire
que notre société ne doit pas se
réformer par décret mais par le dialogue
que le lien entre le président de la
république et les français est une chose
mais qui ne se mesure pas seulement aux
enquêtes d'opinion qu'il doit aussi
passer par la reconnaissance du rôle des
maires je vois que le président de la
république a commencé à le faire des
corps intermédiaires des organisations
syndicales et patronales du monde
associatif afin qu'on puisse emmener
tout le monde dans un processus de
modernisation du pays laissant ceci de
côté puisque nous nous posons la
question des institutions et je dois
dire à cet égard que je suis un partisan
de la vème république
je crois que ceux qui connaissent notre
histoire savent à quel point on peut
remercier le général de gaulle d'avoir
créé et la stabilité dans notre pays
aujourd'hui même un président archi
minoritaire dans l'opinion a les moyens
de gouverner
et je crois que c'est très important
quand on compare avec la situation de
pays voisins de gouvernement précaire
mais mais il faut faire très attention
que cette surpuissance de l'exécutif ne
vire pas au régime de pleins pouvoirs
attention nous avons c'est le risque
l'homme dans son église ce risque parce
que vous avez un président tout puissant
un gouvernement subordonnés et une
majorité à l'assemblée nationale élu sur
le nom du président et qui par
conséquent ne lui résiste pas et le seul
élément de pondération dans nos
institutions le seul contrepoids le seul
contre-pouvoir qui ne fait jamais
d'obstruction et n'empêche pas les
réformes au contraire les soutiens en
les amendes en mai qui exerce aussi un
pouvoir de contrôle face à la toute
puissance du bloc majoritaire
c'est le sénat alors vous avez envie
ville d'ailleurs avait estimé qu'il
était indispensable de le contrôler non
seulement de le contrôler dans la
manière dont il se comportait à l'époque
en une assemblée républicaine et
rappelons-nous 2 puisque le sénat avait
ordonné si mes souvenirs sont bons la
publication du discours de monnerville
sur le général de gaulle aurait on
apprend beaucoup de choses de l'histoire
là se sont dites le nous ce sont les
années 60 que vous faites revenu sur la
santé générale de 58 ans et je vous
remercie
je pense le général de gaulle a rétabli
le sénat dans la plénitude de ses
pouvoirs en 1958 alors que la
constitution de 1946 celle de la
quatrième république les avait diminué
je vous accorde bien volontiers qu'en
1969 il a changé d'avis mais pendant
très longtemps et c'était le discours de
bayeux
quel discours fondateur du général de
gaulle en matière d'institutions qui
montre à quel point le sénat était pour
le thunder s'est toujours opposé à
l'ayrolle de gaulle sans une clause que
son jockey il
son intérêt mais il n'est pas à sens
unique alors à la tour s'élève normand
alors allez-y
autre question peut-être autres
thématiques aussi on peut avancer sur la
commission d'enquêté c'est aussi la
façon dont monsieur je termine sur la
commission de rigueur à lessiver ensuite
monsieur je pense effectivement cette
commission denquête le travail le sénat
il ya donné tout son corps j'en suis
bien d'accord
je vous reviens je pense cependant que
ce n'est pas ainsi qu'il aurait dû se
poser en particulier lorsqu'il n'a pas
respecté la séparation des pouvoirs
entre l'exécutif et le législatif
je pense que le président de la
république n'a pas à répondre une
commission denquête de même que ses plus
proches collaborateurs en ce sens le
secrétaire général de l'elysée ce dont
vous avez occupé la fonction et le
directeur de cabinet et je veux puis là
dessus sur les articles qui ont été
faits et produit par monsieur
professeurs chercheurs en particulier
dans le monde devant vous qui allez
savoir pourquoi vous l'accusé d'abus de
pouvoir en convoquant je considère dinan
2 les jeunes populaires que c'était une
faute fort une faute contre la
séparation des pouvoirs est un élément
essentiel de la république que de les
convoquer à ce niveau là je répondrais
comme une faute c'est une pratique dont
nous ne sommes pas les premiers auteurs
je crois qu'il ne doit pas y avoir dans
la république de pouvoir qui n'est pas
de comptes à rendre
représentant de la nation que son mea
culpa que sympathique surtout quand ce
que surtout quand ce nom ce pouvoir
contrairement à ce qu'avaient voulu
général de gaulle le président de la
république et le chef du gouvernement ce
qui est très renforcée en ce moment
clairement et effectivement il n'y a
plus de contrôle du tout l'élection à
l'assemblée nationale aussi bien pour
monsieur sarkozy que pour monsieur
hollande et que bon monsieur macron
s'est fait avec des gens qui ont dit
dans les deux mois qui suivent l
élection présidentielle
nous voulons donner au président un
députés de son camp et aujourd'hui nos
députés en marche pour l'essentiel ne
sont plus des représentants du peuple
auprès du pouvoir
ce qu'il faut être même si on soutient
ce pouvoir et même au contraire soutenir
le pouvoir sait être des représentants
du parc sont ils ont été des
représentants du gouvernement brand près
du peuple et c'est une grande différence
dire que d'aller vers le peuple pour
expliquer les décisions n'est pas la
même chose que deux
thione le peuple et dont les débats
parlementaires d'être capable de faire
des amendements qui reçoivent une
approbation et qui sont après discussion
on le constate que ce tour et vous avez
déjà été élu avant de rejoindre la
république alors j'ai considéré que ce
que qu'on dit aujourd'hui la de vos
collègues du groupe la république en
marche correspond à la réalité en sursis
ans j'entends dire que vos collègues
c'est ce qu'écrivait franz olivier
giesbert que vous connaissez bien dans
le point il disait que le groupe était
composé de zombies oui france c'est
france et ils s'amusent mais d'un autre
côté qu'est ce qu'il en est un c'est ce
niveau là moi je sais c'est mon
troisième mandat je suis resté 36 ans
mère on peut pas dire que j'ai pas eu
une certaine expérience locale
je suis resté 22 ans par ailleurs vice
président de la région normandie donc et
je soutiens est depuis toujours le
président macron donc vous voyez il n'a
pas à côté de tours et dans le groupe en
marche parce qu'en effet il me semble
que c'est le bon profil se répéter
celui qui a des racines je suis
d'expérience de ces vilains 90 kg
interdiction du cumul de mandats enfin
la tradition du cumul des mandats est
une stupidité absolue dont nous aurons
beaucoup de mal à nous remettre je le
prouve alors on pourra peut-être parler
maintenant dans d'autres sujets qui vous
préoccupent
messieurs c'est la réforme de la justice
monsieur bigot puisque la lavande à
revenir bientôt au sénat et c'est un
autre enjeu du moment même sens on va
pas entrer dans les données techniques
de cette réforme qui reste très
contestée mais dans les professions dans
les dossiers istres avocats dans la
démarche de fonds par un gouvernement
c'est un exemple typique à l'initiative
de philippe bas en 2010 est une mission
confiée à la commission des lois a fait
un rapport sur le fond son de la justice
on va travailler ensemble et nous sommes
arrivés très largement à des formes de
consensus entre des gens de droite et
des gens de gauche parce que la justice
comme la défense comme les affaires
étrangères doit faire l'objet de
consensus
philippe bas à proposer une proposition
de loi qui a été adopté en octobre 2017
qui était en fait un texte qui voulait
servir de travail à madame belloubet les
rapporteurs ont fait un travail assez
consensuel sur lequel nous avons suivi
pour beaucoup le groupe socialiste dans
lequel je suis et la garde des sceaux
n'a fait que mettre de côté tout ce qui
a été proposé par le sénat pour arriver
à une commission mixte paritaire qui
n'aboutit à rien alors que ce texte est
contestée sur le terrain et pourquoi en
arrivant nous pas à trouver des
consensus y compris en prennent des
acteurs de la justice pour faire en
sorte de faire une réforme qui tienne la
route pas tout simplement parce que moi
je les dis à la garde des sceaux
c'est une réforme qui vise avant tout
certes à donner plus de moyens à la
justice mais surtout à faire des
économies
le budget le budget augmente mais en
même temps on essaie de faire avec ce
budget dans des pensées mois donc on
veut numériser
nous étions par exemple d'accord sur la
fusion des tribunaux de grande instance
et des tribunaux d'instance mais à
condition de ne pas faire bouger la
carte judiciaire ça va rester un débat
dans le texte du sénat il est proposé
nous étions d'accord sur ce point de
dire que les modifications des cartes
géographiques notamment des chambres des
tâches et des fameux tribunaux
d'instance qui reste dans le tribunal de
grande instance ne puisse pas être
décidée sans qu'il y ait un travail avec
les élus locaux
ça a été repris à l'assemblée nationale
madame bbb est en marche ont refusé cela
alors que ça va dans le sens de sa
réforme mais avec des garde-fous à 2
mois de la quille a beaucoup de
consensus entre la gauche et la droite
sur ce sujet pas sur tous les autres
si vous voulez vraiment je redis
une chose très importante pour moi la
justice c'est comme la défense et les
affaires étrangères
quelle que soit la majorité au pouvoir
on devrait mettre la justice à l'abri
des clivages et des discussions
politiques
nous avons fait un gros travail de garde
des sceaux a eu la gentillesse de ne
reconnaître n en a pas tenu compte et
ensuite tous les amendements que nous
avons présentés ont été balayés à
l'assemblée nationale et nous nous
retrouvons maintenant avec cette volonté
de passage en force du gouvernement avec
l'appui de sa majorité à l'assemblée
nationale et nous aurions pourtant
peut-être pu comme nous l'avons fait
pour la réforme de la sncf trouver les
voies d'un compromis qui aurait
peut-être au moins il fallait courir la
chance éviter cette radicalisation d
opposition à la réforme avec d'un côté
les magistrats
de l'autre les avocats pour une fois
d'accord et enfin des collectivités
valence de rien très inquiet le réseau
des tribunaux mais sur l'ensemble des
territoires
pourquoi il a joué terroir explique
qu'il ya véritablement et reconnaissons
que dans la première année d'exercice du
pouvoir
le nouveau président peut-être à a forgé
sa propre méthode mais il est temps
maintenant que cette méthode plus
ouverte non seulement à la concertation
avec les forces vives et les
représentants des territoires mais aussi
à un travail constructif avec le sénat
qui une fois encore ne fait pas
d'obstruction
on peut toujours on peut toujours
surmonter l'opposition du sénat
mais ça n'est pas une raison pour ne pas
l'écouter car quand on les écoute on
s'en porte mieux pour le gazole
c'est pas pareil à savourer sur les
gazons répond bon on va pas s'en sortir
en ce qui concerne la réforme de la
justice je suis ça fait trois mois que
je passe à la commission des lois donc
j'ai la plus belle loi que nous ayons
voter c'est en 2000 la loi sur la
présomption d'innocence loi sur la
présomption d'innocence qui a été l'un
des fondements mêmes de la justice et
d'autres républiques et nous l'avions
voté à l'unanimité
et je me rappelle un peu devedjian
patrick devedjian à l'époque puisque moi
j'étais l'un des rapporteurs de la loi
nous voulons aller encore plus loin que
ce que nous mettions dans la loi sur la
présomption d'innocence
depuis nous sommes toujours revenu vers
moins de droits pour les individus plus
de cas de poursuites plus d'aggravation
des peines plus d'emprisonnement moins
de moyens pour les prisons voilà la
réalité des choses est que ce soit sous
la droite sous la gauche c'est la
réalité qui s'est fait lorsque avec
emmanuel macron nous avons eu réfléchi
je lui ai fait de nombreuses que de
nombreuses lettres nombreux écrits sur
la justice et sur la réforme des
institutions avant qu'il ne soit élu
la première chose la justice va avoir un
mot des moyens qu'elle n'a jamais eue
j'ai là les papiers si celui 7 milliards
d'euros actuellement 8 3 milliards
d'euros à la fin du mandat
ça c'est quand même quelque chose
d'important très important la justice a
besoin de moyens
et lorsque je me suis adressé à la garde
et des choses je lui ai dit c'est pas de
nouvelles structures dont on a besoin on
a besoin de moyens donner des moyens
pour mieux fonctionner fait cela avoir
été entendu et bien sûr vous votre
raison j'ai foi il suffisamment a
suffisamment mais vous voterez la
réforme
je verrai savait pas sûr encore
messieurs merci d'avoir participé à cet
échange avec philippe bas c'est
maintenant le temps de la troisième
partie d'auditions publiques avec nos
deux journalistes qui font leur entrée
sur le plateau
merci messieurs revoir bonne chose
[Musique]
pendant qu'elle s'installe oriane
mancini brigitte boucher bonsoir une
question d'un internaute du figure on a
beaucoup de questions d'internautes qui
nous suivent sur le figaro live me
dit-on celle ci j'en retiens une voie là
est ce qu'il est possible d'augmenter
drastiquement les peines encourues pour
parjure ou refus de répondre devant le
sénat c'est une question est ce que vous
y seriez favorable vous avez rappelé le
barème tout à l'heure votre internaute
n'a pas le sentiment que cinq ans de
prison c'est beaucoup ah bah écoute et
puisque ça n'a pas dissuadé votre
interlocuteur du jour de répondre il
considère qu on peut aller plus loin
vous moi je considère que la ceinture du
bénin est suffisamment élevé preuve
brigitte alors bonjour monsieur bah
emmanuel macron a déjà fait deux débats
avec les maires 1 dans l'eure dans le
love on voit que sa cote de popularité
remonte un petit peu on voit que
l'opinion face au mouvement faiblit un
petit peu dans son soutien aux
mouvements
est-ce que vous aussi vous trouvez que
le président est convaincant dans cet
exercice et pour justement atténuer ce
mouvement d gilet jaune
je suis allé à bourgtheroulde dans
l'eure près de rouen et j'ai assisté à
cette première rencontre avec beaucoup
de maires dont un certain nombre de
maires de la manche qui avait répondu à
l'invitation du président de la
république
la performance physique est presque
psychique et intellectuelle du président
de la république est hors de cause
il a su effectivement ali mais cette
réunion d'une manière qui montre que
l'homme a de la ressource et à vrai dire
là au début sinon quand vous avez prouvé
consolider un peu sa situation politique
alors qu'il a devant lui trois années de
mandat
ce ne serait pas plus mal pour le pays
pour cela il faut bien sûr que
mouvement amorcé depuis le mois de
décembre qui consiste à entendre un peu
mieux ce qui vient de la base si j'ose
dire comme ça a été le cas pour le
diesel pour les problèmes de pouvoir
d'achat qui ont été mis en avant par les
gilets jaunes mais comme c'est le cas
aussi pour les attentes des maires pour
les 80 km heure pour les souplesses à
apporter à la décentralisation alors on
aura fait un progrès et j'espère que ce
sera le cas maintenant
dans ces rencontres entre le président
de la république et les maires il ya une
limite à ne pas franchir
c'est très bien pour le président de la
république de tendre l'oreille pour
savoir ce que la population a à dire et
comme les maires savent bien ce que la
population à dire ils peuvent le dire au
président mais en retour
l'exécutif le président de la république
lui-même ne doit pas chercher à
instrumentaliser numéro fond le crédit
des mers auprès de leurs concitoyens
vient du fait que il rassemble tout le
monde au delà des clivages et ils sont
indépendants du pouvoir et donc oui à la
remontée non à l'instrumentalisation
pour l'instant nous n'en sommes pas là
dans la démarche qui consiste à aller à
la rencontre des maires mais le jour où
des mères organiseront dans leur commune
des débats avec les citoyens ils ne
seront pas et en aucun cas ne doivent
l'être
les porte parole du pouvoir ils peuvent
être les porte paroles de leur
population
mais je mets dans ses paroles instants
du pouvoir et un angle assez bien tes de
neutralité dans sa version visité du
débat étant extrêmement l'impartialité
du débat étant extrêmement importante
je crois qu'il est utile et de mettre en
garde contre toute tentation est certes
un peu peur que je ne sais pas moi suivi
la à la séduction c'est ça que nous dit
non c'est parce que je veux dans un jeu
vous dis simplement que il faut laisser
mère toute latitude et toute
indépendance ils ne sont pas les porte
parole de l'elysée ils doivent être les
porte parole de la formation temps juste
il est heureux il est heureux qu'enfin
on commence à s'en rendre compte vous
savez comme je le dit gérard larcher
vous l'avez entendu ces derniers jours
le président du sénat a dit que le
réseau des cinq sens des 550 mille élus
locaux de nos communes
ce sont des français choisis par
d'autres français vivant au milieu des
français connaissant les réalités savent
ce qu'il y a dans la dette dans le coeur
et même dans les tripes des français et
ça c'est très important qu'il soit perdu
on a su avoir l'impression que dans les
18 premiers mois d'exercice de son
pouvoir par le président de macron il
n'avait pas totalement pris en compte
cette réalité qu'il est utile à hull et
les enfants a changé pour l' équilibre
de la république pour faire en sorte que
le lien démocratique de représentation
ne se distingue pas mais qu'au contraire
les élus soit au contact de la barre est
désormais vous diriez que ça a changé
aussi bien avec les élus locaux qu'avec
les parlementaires mais c'est beaucoup
trop tôt pour le dire
il y a pour l'instant une posture qui va
dans le bon sens et personne ne peut le
nier et il était souhaitable depuis
longtemps que cette évolution se fasse
jour
maintenant il faut que les actes suivent
on entend beaucoup parler diesel on
entend parler goerig les garçons 1 km
heure a voté des mesures de
décentralisation juin dernier des
mesures concernant l'organisation des
communes plus récemment il débattra des
communes nouvelles
au mois de février nous votons des
propositions de loi nous attendons
qu'elle soit inscrite à l'assemblée
nationale qui pourra les amendes et de
sorte que nous puissions faire avancer
les libertés locales et mieux
reconnaître les attentes de nos confie
très excité voter été repris tout à fait
il va être discutée d'ailleurs en
commission à l'assemblée nationale il
s'agit de ce qu'on a appelé la loi
anti-casseurs la loi de monsieur
retailleau fait un autre sujet un bon
exemple si vous cherchez des exemples
sont nombreux d'ailleurs dans 2
la chance de droite qui inspire emmanuel
macron aujourd'hui notamment parce que
quand nous avons adopté cette loi le
gouvernement est resté dans une prudente
expectative comme on dit sur la rive est
dans une position de sagesse entre
cinghalais et puis compte tenu de la
crise
il a réalisé que ce serait une bonne
chose de s'inspirer de nos propositions
en les inscrits l'aria leur dure dix ans
à l'assemblée du coup cette loi arrive à
l'assemblée cette semaine en commission
des lois se souvient notamment des
sanctions contre les casseurs cagoulés
un fichier recensant les personnes
interdit de manifester mais pour les
députés en tout cas pour certains
députés de la majorité bien certaines
dispositions posent problème
ils s'inquiètent d'une loi qu'ils jugent
liberticide est ce que vous comprenez
leur inquiétude non je les comprends pas
parce que nous avons au contraire été
très attentif à ce que toutes les
mesures prises dans cette proposition de
loi soit protectrice des libertés ne
s'agit pas du tout de diminuer en quoi
que ce soit la liberté de manifester
enfin casseurs cagoulés qui est
interdite de manifestation il faut
pouvoir prendre des mesures
opérationnelles pour pas les laisser
pénétrer dans le périmètre de la
manifestation
c'est juste ça et pour ça ces mesures
opérationnelles elle repose sur
l'existence d'un fichier mais ce fichier
il est nécessaire à la sécurité publique
manifester est cassé c'est pas la même
chose
les gens qui manifestent ont intérêt eux
mêmes à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de casseurs
ces essaims de frelons qui se greffe sur
des manifestations pacifiques et qui
finissent par disqualifier les
manifestants pacifiques même alors il
faut prendre des mesures il est plus que
temps de le faire on a été un peu mou du
genou
si vous me passez l'expression avant de
décidé de passer à la vitesse supérieure
dans ce domaine aujourd'hui oui on est
lanceurs de balles de défense ces fameux
lbd est ce que vous pensez qu'il faut
mieux encadrer leur utilisation que
faut-il faire à votre avis on dit qu'il
ya eu des dérapages de la part de
policiers de gendarmes sur des
manifestants ont des droits est
parfaitement dans son rôle en mettant en
garde contre l'utilisation abusive de
ses moyens simplement je vous ferai
remarquer que quand on écoute les forces
de police qui sont soumises à rude
épreuve une pression qui est parfois va
jusque ce qui parfois pas jusqu'au
débordement ont besoin de pouvoir donner
des coups de semonce et essayer
d'arrêter les initiatives d'une minorité
d'activistes qui joignent les
manifestants c'est très important de le
faire en sachant que si on n'utilise
plus ses moyens alors la police risque
d'être conduite à utiliser des moyens
encore plus forts qui sont à sa
disposition de vous 22 points a dit le
ministre donc soyons là véritablement
très attentif à la fois à respecter la
protection des citoyens
les libertés publiques qui suppose une
bonne maîtrise de l'emploi de ces
instruments par la force publique sans
pour autant les prairies bon moyen de
régulation comme un mot sur le rapport
parlementaire sur la bioéthique qui a
été rendu la semaine dernière un autre
sujet rendu à l'assemblée nationale et
propose de nombreux bouleversements la
pma pour tout ça c'est une promesse de
campagne d'emmanuel macron mais
également la levée de l'anonymat du don
de sperme la possibilité de procréation
post nos termes est ce que vous pensez
être le rapport est est ce que le
gouvernement doit suivre le rapport
selon vous tout ceci ne forme pas un
tout chacune de ces questions est en soi
une question très difficile à traiter
il ya un certain nombre d'attentes qui
s'exprime dans la société je ne dis pas
des attentes de la société
mais dans la société il faut voir si ces
attentes
et sont éthiques ou pas c'est le débat
parlementaire qui doit tendre décidé une
petite équipe qui fait un rapport a le
mérite d'entendre beaucoup de parties
prenantes les conclusions sur la table
je vous ferai remarquer qu'il y aussi
les conclusions du conseil national
consultatif d'éthique pour les sciences
de la vie et qu'il y a également un très
bon rapport du conseil d'état qui est
clair la décision émane son personnel et
leurs éléments doute le président de la
république a été lui-même extrêmement
prudent il se souvient des déchirures de
la société française à l'occasion du
débat sur le mariage pour tout ce qui
justifie pleinement que un moment de
forte tension sociale dans notre pays
ils prennent le temps nécessaire pour
essayer de dégager des courses 32 temps
nécessaire c'est à dire qu'il faut louer
ça nous serons prêts à y travailler
nous mettrons en place je le crois une
commission spéciale et c'est
collectivement nous déterminerons notre
position mais le calendrier n'est pas le
bon pour vous il faut attendre un peu
vous savez les calendriers du
gouvernement ont une vertu c'est qu'ils
sont provisoires on a pu le constater
alors faute personnelle philippe bas
vous êtes hostile ali vg comme
françois-xavier belani non j'ai été un
très proche collaborateur de simone veil
entre 93 et 95 et j'ai pu à son contact
mesurer les situations de détresse
mettant en péril
vie de nombreuses femmes auxquelles elle
a voulu mettre fin par la loi veil de
je crois que cette loi est aujourd'hui
pleinement acceptée par la société
française la question de l'ibg et pour
chaque femme une question qu'elle doit
se poser en conscience mais la loi
elle-même me paraît faire partie des
dispositions est tangible dans notre
république du coup ça ne vous gêne pas
que françois-xavier bellamy qui est
potentiellement tête de liste et les
républicains pour les européennes est
cette conviction propre je dirais
d'abord puisqu'il s'agit des élections
européennes que j'espère que ma famille
politique désignera un chef de file même
si le président de cette formation
politique
naturellement et le leader dans le débat
public
un chef de file qui respecte la
tradition de nos familles politiques
je me souviens en 2002 j'étais aux côtés
de jacques chirac quand il a créé l'ump
à partir du rpr et des forces qui
composaient alors l'udf vous espérez le
monde était favorable à l'europe
notre position doit être de mon point de
vue non à l'euro béatitude à la mode du
président de la république non à
l'euroscepticisme absolu et même leur
hostilité des forces extrêmes pour
d'accord un euro réalisme qui consiste à
dire l'europe c'est la paix l'europe
c'est notre fer de lance
question monsieur basque la question
c'est ce que vous êtes pour ou contre je
veux répondre parce que repas si vous
avez terminé à mon nom j'ai bien compris
même en rêve tous je veux vous dire une
chose très importante de mon point de
vue c'est que cette position qui est
celle de l'euro en lice mme elle dit oui
à l'europe que l'europe soit notre fer
de lance pour la conquête de nouveaux
marchés face aux mastodontes qui sont
les états continents qui sont en
concurrence avec nous elle doit nous
protéger sur la pollution lumineuse
l'immigration l'insécurité
elle doit aussi assurer la paix entre
nos pays c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous ne pouvons pas être sur le reculoir
vis-à-vis de l'europe et ce faisant je
vous donne quelques éléments pour
répondre à votre question
j'attends de notre candidat fut-il
monsieur belhani qu'ils répondent oui et
qu ils cochent toutes les cases pour que
nous ayons une campagne extrêmement
dynamique sur l'europe a répondu le
débat
en effet le professeur aujourd'hui
d'être un jeu résume un catholique
conservateur sur un certain nombre de
sujets li vg la pma pour tout le mariage
pour tous est ce que ça vous choque est
ce que vous estimez qu'il a pas le bon
profil c'était la question j'estime que
le sentiment religieux ou non religieux
de chacun l'homme regarde montpellier
dans un sens ni dans l'autre
c'est un leader un vrai leader qui soit
capable de tirer liste sur les baskets
et des prises parce que si ça reste que
vous parlez de cocher les canettes
comment ils cochent la case et bien
véritablement je ne le sais pas alors à
laquelle je vous réponds mais je
souhaite qu'il se dévoile davantage va
que voir le vérifie nadal est allé en
avance sur la question européenne encore
que les républicains seront au-dessus
nicolas dupont aignan aux européennes
est ce qu'ils peuvent se retrouver à 8
10 % est ce que c'est le risque pour
vous aujourd'hui vous avez les
pronostics politique c'est plutôt vous
qui pouvez les faire moi je suis dans
l'action je dis ce que sont mes
convictions et ce que nous devons
proposer de mon point de vue sur
l'europe à nos concitoyens
alors maintenant les résultats nous
verrons bien ce qu'il se dit je
considère que propose laurent vote je
considère que la situation est ma
famille politique
mais les bonnes depuis l'élection
présidentielle nous pensions qu'au
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle nous avions touché le
fond je remarque que depuis la
nomination d'edouard philippe à matignon
une partie de l'électorat traditionnel
de notre famille politique a peut-être
provisoirement rejoint la majorité et je
me dis que si notre démocratie veut
avoir plus de choix entre monsieur macro
et les extrêmes en 2022
il serait bon que ma famille politique
se redresse mais pour sa maman mais
elles ne peuvent pas se dispenser d'un
double effort celui de regrouper toutes
les chapelles au sein d'un vrai
rassemblement et deuxièmement celui
d'une refondation des idées à laquelle
je suis d'ailleurs tout à fait prêt à
participer avec beaucoup d'autres pour
offrir aux français qui sont les déçus
du maquereau nice qu'aujourd'hui la vie
des nations démocrate vous dites que
l'accueil soit pas extrême
philippe bas vous dites que la situation
de notre parti n'est pas beau mais c'est
notre époque est ce que le rock est à
même de la rendre meilleure cette
situation à ce qu'il est l'homme qu'il
faut à ce parti et j'estime depuis sa
désignation il ya un an qu'il faut lui
laisser le forcément ça nous aurons
l'occasion
mais les offert des points d'étape
notamment en fonction des échéances à la
fin des lectorats joue sa peau et nous
en discuterons en famille on peut y
avoir un putsch au lendemain des
européennes
ça vous plaît est-ce qu'il jouait sans
son poste de président du parti
c'est une question qui est en réalité
tout à fait secondaires par rapport aux
questions essentielles bon je viens on
va terminer sa gestion moteur avoue
jugerait essentiel sinon fondamentale
celle du bric site puisque notre région
ainsi que les autres en seraient
particulièrement touchés par les
conséquences de ce break site alors et
douar sidi pas à déclencher un plan le
parlement a voté une loi pour faire face
aux conséquences du bric site est ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous dites la france est
prête très france subira de plein fouet
un certain nombre d'inconvénients d'une
réussite qui va diminuer la croissance
dans toute l'europe et pas simplement en
grande bretagne les premières victimes
seront bien sûr les britanniques mais
nous ne sommes pas à l'abri malgré
toutes les précautions qui peuvent être
prises de losne de choc du mexique mais
le bric site n'est pas encore fait la
situation politique de la
grande-bretagne est très précaire
aujourd'hui et donc tous les espoirs
sont encore permis merci beaucoup au
filet bas d'abord été avec nous
aujourd'hui
merci encore d'avoir répondu longuement
à toutes nos interrogations bien sûr la
semaine prochaine c'est le commissaire
europe 1 pierre moscovici qui sera votre
place
merci encore merci mesdames merci à tous
a très vite
[Musique]